why are you a self-hating Asian I love
you think I'm self-hating yeah why are
you selfish I love my people you how
dare you oh yeah why do you talk [__]
about selfies I'm not talking [__] about
it you talk how many Asian friends do
you have thousands name one John name
one John chose your friend John he's my
friend I'm gonna message him right yeah
message him we talk about harid and
Kumar John Cho yeah I was in here how
about you vote tax and who responds to
this job first yeah
I only know him on Instagram
like good all right so John Cho Steven
Yoon
how about one non-korean
oh [__] oh you wanna go there name
Aquafina
she's happy all right but she's still
not full
oh Ali Wong Ali Ali
yeah yeah yeah my Muslim friend Ali
oh
yeah Ali Wong Steve Byrne he's half Ken
Jung I'm making rattle it off yeah
you're rounding off Koreans you keep
doing yeah you take a lot of careers
yeah uh Michelle Yao congratulations on
the Oscar your friends from Michelle
yeah I did one movie with her does she
hate you she does
and also Jamie Lee Curtis
congratulations she's not Asian I know I
didn't move with belief
hey man it sounds like you're really
biased man you either like Koreans or
famous people
what about normal Asians you don't oh
yeah because if I name them you won't
know them what's his name one Frank
Frank
that's Latino
[Laughter]
threw me in a corner listen I know a lot
of Asians man
you know and I love I love John Legend's
man yeah I I you know Dad fan
that doesn't sound like friends okay I
know but it's uh you know we know each
other Southeast Asian and you guys are
yeah it doesn't sound good so far wow
he's been super you know bob every time
I've met out with Bobby I've spoken to
him he's always been super nice to me
and I hear these stories about him
having fighting literally having Kung Fu
fights with everybody
what happened man like yeah someone
tried to kick you in the face I've been
beat up a lot but my point is this by
like half the people on that poster I
think yeah but I've but here's the thing
dude I'm a survivor
yeah I mean and I I also don't like um I
don't take [__] okay and I'm you know
I'm confrontational really bad for my I
fight for my stage time yeah that's not
the do you fight for stage
do I fight for stage time yeah back in
the day no when you're younger when
you're good people give it to you I know
when you were first starting out yeah
you got you got stage
when you're good people give it to you
okay oh you can't have to fight people
in the yeah
[Laughter]
I grew up in comedy that was a
completely different here we go here
comes Stories
the villain origin story this is why I'm
a piece of [__]
it was so much harder for me than that
you don't understand why
oh my God I'm being nationally famous
the only way this is gonna work right is
we have to do a Tit for Tat oh let me
get wow what I need to get out okay sure
so in the 90s all right there was only a
couple of us and it was much harder to
get stage time when you were a minority
okay I feel like now I feel like now
it's much easier not that I'm saying it
was hard for you right but it was a
completely different environment okay
all right so back in the day I had to
really [__] scrap okay right to get
my time but what does that mean what I'm
saying to you is that that's why I have
all these issues [__] people but what
but why did this beef come out like how
does this come about specifically so you
like obviously we all scrapped for stage
time but I never like like fought
another comic to be like [__] you why
did you get stage time you know I mean
the scrapping was like uh it was it was
a metaphor
station was like I need to try to
because because back in the day right if
you if you had two Asian Comics right in
San Diego was where I started right
you're already like you know it's hard
enough being one Asian guy so we're I
know we just they pit us against each
other yeah like the Mexicans fought each
other like George and Carlos Mencia
didn't get along right so they get
pitted up against it but it's a white
people's fault all right because they
weren't inclusive right so they made us
[__] books so you don't take
responsibility I refuse okay that's very
yeah yeah very enlightened okay it's
very evolved let's go back so here we go
let's start from the beginning oh my God
what I'm gonna say to you is I love you
so much I love you thanks for doing this
but the last thing I want to say about
him and that's this is all I'm gonna say
about what did we injure him properly no
let him finish his thoughts all right
let's go um ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen
he was